c'était pissé dans un violon on est
juste que le minimum que de que le
minimum pour des pays civilisés c'est de
ne pas cautionner des aberrations
est-ce que tu sais que dans le désert on
va climatiser c'est une aberration donc
c'est un coup de com de bafouer de
l'homme c'est un couple
la Coupe du monde allait se réveiller
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas d'hier de
d'avant-hier qu'on s'est rendu compte
que la Coupe du monde était attribuée au
Qatar
on a entendu personne quand on vend au
Qatar on entend personne quand on vend
sur le gouvernement vend au kata on
entend personne
ouvriers qui sont morts on a entendu
pendant la construction les
constructions du stade on a entendu
quelqu'un